speaking of big problems the president
of the united states
obviously has a severe case of ops this
is old person
syndrome something is not right with joe
biden we all know it
and they can't hide him forever and they
have been leaking him out a little bit
more
every now and again he'll take a
question when he's not supposed to and
then often he says oh i'm going to get
in trouble for that
or he walks up to a microphone and sort
of blathers some incoherent
nonsense well now former presidential
physician
ronnie jackson is coming out and talking
about what he thinks is going on
with biden this is not some crazy random
conspiracy theorist off the street
this guy was a presidential physician
under george bush
under barack obama and under donald
trump
take a listen absolutely sean and i've
been saying this from the very beginning
i've been saying
that something's going on here i was
saying this when he was candidate joe
biden
and i've been saying that it's only
going to get worse and guess what we're
watching that happen right before our
eyes right now
and i i'm at the point right now where
you know i went from you know telling
people we should be concerned about what
might potentially be going on
to to now saying hey what are what is
happening right now where
where are the the the people in in our
academic medicine that were out there
calling for
for president trump to have a cognitive
test where are these people there's
something seriously going on with this
man right now and you know i think that
he's either gonna
he's either gonna resign they're gonna
convince him to resign from office at
some point in the near future for
medical issues
or they're going to have to use the 25th
amendment to get rid of this man right
now
there's some serious stuff going on
right now and if they do that it'll be
the president's cabinet that initiates
that
and if you've got to imagine if you're a
cabinet member right now if you're the
president of secretary of defense or
secretary of treasury or his attorney
general you have to be looking at him
right now and thinking to yourself like
what is going on can i take direction
from this man right now and i think
that's going to start happening pretty
soon i think there's going to be some
serious pushback
from the white house and from the left
to to do something about what's going on
because you mentioned in your opening
this is a national security issue at
this point sean it really is
okay that's ronnie jackson former
presidential physician he's not mincing
words there and
basically sounds to me like he's telling
the truth
i don't know what is wrong with joe
biden i am not a doctor and i'm
certainly not joe biden's doctor and
he's not joe biden's doctor either
but he does know a little something
about
medicine he knows a little something
about what it's like to care for the
president
of the united states and he's also just
telling us something
that we all know right he's just telling
us something that we all can see and yet
it's
not shown on mainstream media anywhere
and what do we do about that chasm what
do we do about the divide
between what we all can see and what
mainstream will allow us to process
together
right because that's the only thing that
kind of holds us together as a nation
it's like this is why we need a sane and
decent and honest media
it's like we're all seeing different
stories right now and depending on who
you follow on twitter and
what youtube shows you watch and
anything else like think how different
your
the set of facts that you guys know and
the ideas that you care about
from watching this show let's say think
how different that is
than someone who's only watching msnbc
or only watching cnn
it's it's pretty staggeringly different
so there was this cnn town hall biden
babbled like i mean it was just
absolutely extraordinary can we grab
that quote
we're gonna try to grab a quote from it
i'm going to redo something if we can
pull it up in time
i'm going to redo something that biden
said i think it was originally tweeted
maybe by ali betstucky or somebody over
there
a quote card i sent it out on twitter a
couple days ago we'll see if we can grab
it i think from friday um
biden also the other day was doing a
little press conference and he said he
was on the judiciary committee 150 years
ago
which if that's true uh well then
then he's a vampire um so what do we do
about this i mean look at at the end of
the day
uh you know i think this is a little
sort of similar
ah there we go we got the quote i'll get
to it in just a second can you make that
a little bit bigger if possible on the
prompter
um i think this is sort of similar to
the airlock situation with covid
lab leak so for about a year there was a
certain amount of people
online who were saying oh there is a
chance
that kovid leaked from a wuhan lab
there's a chance that maybe we had
funded some of this stuff
like there's a chance right and what
were they told they were told that they
were conspiracy theorists
they were told they were crazy people
they were told that they should be
banned from twitter and everywhere else
and then for a year that basically went
on and then remember what happened about
a month ago jon stewart
went on stephen colbert's show and said
something about the covid lab league
theory and then suddenly
everyone in the mainstream media felt
that they could talk about it because
the airlock had basically
been broken right so it's like oh jon
stewart said it a good
decent standard liberal has said it so
now we can all say what those crazy
right-wingers
were saying this entire time and i sense
that's going to be exactly what happens
mark my words i'm saying this at the end
of july
2021. mark my words that's sort of
what's going to be
what's going to happen here that it's
going to be something like barack obama
over the next couple months will
probably
be in an interview and do one off-handed
sentence where he
he'll be like something like oh you know
joe isn't exactly
what he used to be or maybe joe's lost
the staff a step or
or maybe it'll be as far as maybe joe
should think about stepping down or
something like that
and then suddenly everyone in the media
is going to pretend
that now they can all talk about it and
that you know suddenly all the people
who are they were calling crazy for
talking about it this whole
time like i think you got the point
there so okay i'm going to read this
quote this is an exact
quote that joe biden said to
don lemon at this cnn town hall i have
to look a little low because we're doing
this off the computer here but just
listen to the quote
you tell me if this makes sense i can't
even read it as slowly and
confused as joe biden but just tell me
if this makes any sense
and the question is whether or not we
should be in a position
where our why can't the experts say we
know
that this virus is in fact it's going to
be
or excuse we know why all the drugs
approved are not temporarily approved
but permanently approved that's underway
too that's just one
little thing and you can watch the video
on that and i just again
i just want to say one other thing this
is not me being partisan or me being an
[ __ ] or me not
being sympathetic to old people or
people with cognitive decline or any of
those things okay
i've told you guys this before i spent a
lot of time
in new york with my with my grandma who
had
the beginnings of dementia in the last
couple years of her life and was
constantly repeating herself and
forgetting
things and becoming frustrated and guess
what there was actually some beauty to
it too because in some ways she forgot a
lot of the things that she used to worry
about and complained about she really
became
a really wonderful quite spectacular
person at the at the end of her life she
always was but really like we
we bonded in an incredible way and
because i was doing stand-up at night
i had a lot of free time during the day
and i would take her to doctors several
times a week
and she had other health things too and
i would take her to doctors and the
repetition and taking the cognitive
tests and all of those things
so i don't say any of this lightly but
like if you're one of if you're a
journalist
if you're a journalist right now who's
not saying something about something we
all can see are you a journalist
and if you're someone who believes that
america is good and you believe that the
office of the presidency matters and
that any of the political stuff that any
of this matters
like and you're trying to hide it or not
talk about what you can see
because it's your guy in office like are
you are you a
patriotic american at that point like so
i'm not a conspiracy theorist those of
you that are seeing these things you're
not conspiracy theorists you're not
crazy people i don't think you're trying
to be dicks about it i'm certainly not
trying to be a dick about it
but something ain't right